Marine Le Pen mal préparée essoré c'est
l'image qui reste du débat d'entre-deux
tours de 2017 une défaite qui hante son
entourage elle-même a prévenu ses
équipes pas question de surcharger son
programme à l'approche de l'échéance
depuis hier Marine Le Pen s'est mise au
calme chez elle pour deux jours de
travail avec ses conseillers une chose
horrible la veille d'un débat mais en
fait je pense que ils ont chacun leurs
qualités etc mais je crois qu'aucun des
deux n'est un grand débatteur pourquoi
mais pour ce que je les observé depuis
un bout de temps
Emmanuel Macron il lui arrive de
prononcer de très bons discours bon lui
arrive aussi d'être trop long etc alors
avoir un débat quasiment entre la
République en marche et le rassemblement
national le Front national Heidi
monsieur le Président de la République
il n'a pas compris que c'était exprès
peut-être un débat à 4 contre
si Emmanuel Macron présidera par exemple
le Conseil des ministres mercredi matin
il travaille également les thèmes clés
du débat entouré de sa garde rapprochée
l'objectif sera à la fois de valoriser
son bilan et de convaincre sur son
projet
sa stratégie pour le débat se concentrer
plus sur le fond que sur la forme avec
l'espoir de coincé Marine Le Pen sur ses
incohérences notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat Marine Le Pen elle est très
entraînée elle a fait beaucoup plus de
débats que lui et elle est en plus elle
c'est la cinquième campagne
présidentielle dans lequel elle joue un
rôle important deux fois au côté de son
père mais qu'elle avait vraiment aidé
trois fois pour elle bon lui c'est un
débutant c'est c'était la première fois
bon les mauvaises langues dit appelle le
News rnews désormais j'ai entendu ça
écoutez franchement ne venez pas sur ce
ne venez pas sur ce terrain parce que
vraiment bonjour Vincent non mais
comment vous
moi je suis fasciné sidéré toujours
parce que je regarde ça comme témoin et
je vois effectivement alors elle mange
pas des enfants encore Marine Le Pen
mais il reste 8 jours
un filet de bœuf
qui a été cuit à la broche et ses
petites pommes de terre avec
un petit peu de jus de viande
vous l'avez déjà le goût dans la bouche
oui c'est une vraie torture là que de
regarder la sauce couler sur les pommes
de terre le premier kebab dans l'espace
oui vous avez bien entendu c'est l'idée
d'un restaurateur turc pour fêter 61 ans
du premier vol habité dans l'espace
ballon gonflé à l'hélium vous voyez ça
alors il y a eu des balles à la
rédaction est-ce que c'est un kebab
est-ce que c'est un kefta en tout cas ce
turc a pu récupérer la brochette à son
retour sur la planète Terre
[Rires]
une fois pêché la tradition veut que
l'espadon reçoivent les honneurs des
hommes pour son courage
[Musique]
sa mort va permettre à plusieurs
familles de vivre
ces hommes savent qu'il faut exploiter
la mer avec discernement
pour que leur descendants puissent
continuer à en vivre je pense que 50 kg
j'aurais mis au plus grosses portions en
garçon et puis des petites portions
enfiles parce qu'on a besoin plus
d'énergie aussi pour pour carburer etc
malheureusement on n'est pas sur le
principe d'équité mais l'égalité ce qui
m'amuse c'est d'apporter dans votre
équipe on sent que ça vous plaît pas ce
qui se passe mais pas du tout ce qui
m'amuse c'est d'apporter la
contradiction à ce que j'interroge me
semble-t-il
faut arrêter et souvent vous le dites
d'ailleurs parce que les journalistes ne
sont pas plus objectif
de temps en temps et de plus en plus
mais bon on est à Koh-Lanta on est très
clairement des sauvages depuis 21 jours
mais là on va s'offrir une petite ta
cartade de
de raffinité voilà c'est ça